David starts off this hour in Ruston
Louisiana hi David how are you good how
are you
better than I deserve what's up great
hey well my question was whether to sell
my house to pay off debt or to file
chapter 13 bankruptcy and the debt is
mostly from a business that I recently
closed sorry how long you have the
business only two years mmm
and once you're done if you got its
80,000 on the business and it's its
business credit card that's personally
guaranteed and you know got about
another 63 of personal debt I'm one not
including my house
credit cards personal loans ours
how much do you own your course not my
child would talk about 5,000 my lights
caught up 3,000 mmm old are you 51 how
long you been married 29 years kind of
business position which was a retail
nutrition store okay what are you doing
now
I just had a new job this week as a
insurance marketing around and that's
what I did
in the past I got laid off three years
ago and was just frustrated and fed up
and started this business and we took
out a bunch of that mm-hmm
so um you got a hundred and forty
thousand dollars in debt on how much
equity in your home I'm hoping if I sell
it I could get clear about 40 to 45
pounds so doesn't really solve the
problem I was hoping I could settled all
the business debt I haven't paid on in
mine I'm hoping I could sell it out
let's just let's just stop you don't
have business debt you've heard I know
your parental debt in your mind it was
done for the business but legally you
took out personal credit cards and you
used them for the business right that's
the law and so legally that there's no
distinction in their mind between
business and personal you got a bunch of
credit card debt that haven't been paid
and how long some as long is 6 right
months and some just two or three months
mmm
what's your household income now well my
life also just started a new job she was
laid off in December started a new job
six weeks ago so now back up to about
105 we were basically you know probably
nothing for a month okay good
all right let's walk through the
priorities because I've been where you
are plus a few zeros and it's scary is
cred the first thing is you guys need to
sit down tonight and turn off the
television and go this is a Monopoly
game and we just lost this round it does
not mean our marriage needs to end if
you don't have stress on your marriage
in this situation you're not human right
do not let this stuff take your marriage
okay the second thing that happens is
when a guy in particular closes a
business it your self-esteem takes a hit
you feel like a failure
I did I but I didn't just close it I
crashed it it was a mushroom cloud where
I was you know so I was explosions
everywhere but and I was a lot younger I
mean you're more like my age now I'm 58
you're 51 but you know so you're more
mature to be able to look at it with a
better lens but just the same you tried
something it didn't work cut yourself
some slack okay emotionally it's okay
all right you just tried something man
it's all right you're gonna be okay your
family's not ruined for life it's not
over
I then once I've done those two things
the marriage is protected you cut
yourself some grace and you go well crap
now we got to clean out the basement
it's a mess
[Laughter]
all right so how we gonna do that well
we can sell the house
it doesn't really solve the problem
though completely no not even close I
mean it's 40,000 out of 140,000 so what
I would do is do you like the house we
do I mean the mortgage is you know it's
kind of putting a strain on it oh it is
how big is this mortgage well it 1550
okay with a 80 with an $8,000 income a
month it's in - yeah you're okay it's
not the out of the there so what I would
do is this let's sit down the two of you
need to be working this together it's
very important that both of you
communicate on this and that we say
here's how we're gonna clean it up okay
so first thing is food you got the money
to do that
second thing is lights and water you got
the money to do that third thing is pay
the house payment you got the money to
do that fourth thing is pay the car
payment and keep gas in the car you got
somebody to do that so food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
civics class what calls those
necessities if you're old enough to have
gone to a civics class okay that's a
necessity that's not a want we took care
of your living and you've still got
money left over now how much money we
got we got a pretty good pile of money
because you make good money and I
suspect your incomes going to go up
between the two of you over the coming
year - as you're emotionally start
healing and this stuff gets further in
the rearview mirror you'll get more and
more focused and your incomes are going
to come back up even further than they
are now so I would then attack the I
would let the bad debt that's bad just
let it sit there and let it get worse
let it get worse and then I would I
would try to pay off a bunch of the
current debt like you know make a list
of stuff you're current on and do it
that snowball with that and that sounds
like the 60,000 portion the non-business
portion of the way you were discussing
it earlier is the stuff you're current
with right yeah because you've been
jumping around trying to a whole bunch
of stuff and you didn't have these jobs
that just kicked in 105 thousand then it
could be current on $60,000 for the debt
and still paid the other stuff I was
talking about now the 80,000 is gonna
sit there
okay and let's let it sit there that's
okay because that was the plan anyway
and a bunch of that was credit card a
bunch of it was what the ad
it's business credit cards there's one
small loan that was about fifteen
hundred the rest of it business credit
card so you'll just sit there they're
just going to come back they're gonna go
back you file bankruptcy they're gonna
go bad anyway right so we're not gonna
file bankruptcy you're not bankrupt you
can work your way through it and what I
would do is spend you know say how fast
can we help sixty thousand bucks and be
debt free except that business mess and
then once you've done that that make
that's probably take you year and a half
two years something like that and you
pay off the sixty and your debt free
accept that business debt then you've
got to start going to those 80s and
settling those one at a time pennies on
the dollar like you were thinking about
if at any point in this it looks like
the house selling the house is your
financial salvation you can always sell
the house but I don't think you're going
to need to I think you got about three
and a half years of beans and rice and
being on a tight budget and you're going
to be debt-free by settling a bunch of
the eighty and by paying the sixty and
working a plan hold on to your marriage
man you can do this this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]